um how's the NHS which is 75 today
changed in the time that you have been
uh involved with it yeah so I was I
still work as a bank nurse and I've been
working in the NHS for over 30 years
it's changed a huge amount uh when I go
back and do Bank shifts now the patients
are in hospital often much sicker
um you know when I was uh training if
you went in for surgery like for a
hernia or varicose veins you're in for
nearly a week there will day cases now
and one you know a good example that I
give is patients with HIV when I was a
student nurse I used to look after
patients dying of AIDS and now people
with HIV can live uh you know a lies
where they're not passing on the virus
to Partners they're able to have
children because of the medicines and
advances in the treatment of HIV which
is amazing and superb and fantastic but
we've got a big number for you 7.4
million pounds at 7.4 million people
forgive me in the backlog waiting for
treatment
yeah so what what we are doing in
England and we're only responsible for
healthcare in England is we are getting
those waiting lists uh down in terms of
how long people are well what I would
say to patients what matters is how long
they're waiting they're not really
worried about who else is on the waiting
list they want to know when their
procedure or operation is happening and
we've significantly reduced that uh
delay so we've virtually eliminated a
two-year weight that's 7.4 million of
people and that probably will go up
higher because we're offering more
procedures even higher so what I'm
saying is but the length of time people
are waiting for their procedures is
actually going down and that's what
matters to patients what's it going to
go up to so but what it's going to go
down to is going to go higher so what's
it going to do so we're gonna we've got
the two-year weights down we've got the
18-month weights down and we're now
working on those waiting uh for a year
um to try and get those weights down
further in Wales where labor run the NHS
there's thousands of people like that
talking about that massive number well I
said it's going to go higher so I'm
asking you reasonable question how much
higher is it going to go I think it's
important for people in Wales to know
that they are still waiting to years
because the same interventions haven't
been put in in Wales there will always
be people being added to the waiting
list because we're introducing more
procedures we're able to it's never
going to come below 7.4 million I'm not
saying that but I'm saying that there
will always be people waiting for
procedures whether that's outpatients
procedures operations investigations
um what matters to patients what matters
is how long uh how many people are on
the waiting list you said that number
which is massive is going to go higher
I'm asking you we've always been very
clear that after covid when routine
procedures were shut down quite rightly
to protect a focus on covid we always
have the waiting list would go up before
it would start to come down so it will
start to come down but when I go up so
it will go up before it comes I've given
you enough chances now to that to
clarify whether it was a missed speaker
or not if it wasn't if it's going to go
higher it's reasonable to ask you how
much higher it's going to go so you know
what our focus on is the waiting well
because what's important to patients is
how long they have to wait and in
England were able to say to patients
you're not waiting two years you're not
waiting 18 months you're waiting less
than a year and we want to get that down
further that's when I see constituents
in my own surgery surgeries in my
constituency they want to know how
quickly can I get my hip operation done
how quickly can I see the consultant and
when we're able to say that that is
reducing all the time through our
investment and the hard work of NHS
staff they're not worried about who else
is on that waiting list they want to
know
if I may I allowed you to answer that
question
um I said that number is 7.4 million had
was higher and you said it will go
higher before it comes down so you must
have an idea how much higher it's going
to go that's my question well you know
that's a clinical decision that when
people go on to the waiting list but we
have always been clear when we're coming
out because you know I'm not going to
say a figure because there's a whole
range of reasons why people go onto the
waiting list it may be for operations it
may be for investigations but it's going
to get worse before it gets better we've
always been clear about that and the
Prime Minister has been clear that that
getting that waiting list down is uh one
of his key priorities but we have he's
also been on honest that though that
will go up before it comes down okay
you're embarrassed by that number I
think it's tremendous that given that
number on that waiting list that we're
able to get people seen much quicker
than they were this time last year so
this time last year people were waiting
for over two years we've managed in a
very short space of time to virtually
eliminate that uh in April we were able
to say that over 90 percent of people
were no longer waiting uh 18 months and
now we're focused on on the the people
waiting for a year do you think well
because we closed down the health
service for two years to focus on code
but that's a massive according to the
former Health secretary he was also
former chair of the health and select
committee he said the NHS in England
when he was chair of the committee now
the chancellor of course the NHS in
England is short of 12 000 Hospital
doctors and more than 50 000 nurses and
midwives he said that that had been a
problem that was uh getting worse uh
year on year he also said the number of
full-time equivalent GPS fell by more
than 700 over three years to March
2022 that takes us back to March 2019 we
weren't in a pandemic then and
absolutely and that's why we were
introduced the long-term Workforce plan
we've been training more doctors and
nurses so compared to this time last
year we've got 12 000 more nurses 5 000
more doctors in my area which is mental
health we're recruiting 27 000 more
staff we've already reached that 20 000
number so we're putting record numbers
of Staff into the Health Service and
with the announcement last week of the
long-term Workforce plan that will be on
an ongoing basis so that over the next
15 years we've got a pipeline of a range
of healthcare professionals with a range
of ways of entering from apprenticeships
to associate routes to flexible learning
and more clinical based learning future
proof the staff can you accept that it's
not just the pandemic that has
exacerbated but in my 30 years of
working in the NHS there's always been
challenges
um you know it's not you accept that
it's not just the pandemic of course you
know there are challenges in healthcare
which are the same challenges that labor
face where they run the Health Service
in Wales and actually their waiting
lists are much uh higher than ours or
where the s p won the health services in
Scotland their challenge is that all
Healthcare Systems around the world are
facing right now Sergio Javid and Tony
Blair both suggesting that some patients
should be charged for using the NHS good
idea well I know that you know Tony
Blair has also come out and said that
that you know he wants to see more
private uh Healthcare uh being available
and for people to start paying towards
that that's not the position of the
government uh we're absolutely clear
that the NHS is free at the point of
views people pay for the NHS through
their taxes and National Insurance and
they pay quite a lot of money towards
that but it will remain free at the
point of use when people need it okay
the leader of the opposition writing in
the Daily Mirror to say that we should
embrace new technologies focusing on
preventing illnesses in the first place
and ensuring we have more care in the
community I'm guessing you agree with
them oh absolutely and that's part of
the work that we're doing
um you know part of the uh work is is
making sure that any uh research we've
just announced 96 uh billion for
research uh development is to get that
embedded um at the uh the bedside so
that patients are getting full advantage
one example for example is the Royal
Marsden who are now using new AI
technology so that when they're looking
at scans the lumps and bumps that are
not necessarily visible to the human eye
AI will pick that up and be able to
guide those Radiologists as to whether
that's likely to be cancer or not so you
know this technology is actually uh
being embedded throughout the NHS as we
speak veterans Minister Johnny Mercer on
the program yesterday I'm sure you're
aware Twitter lit up when he suggested
that it was a choice for people to want
to use uh food banks he was he then was
more specific and said it was a choice
for military personnel if they want to
use food banks do you agree with him
well people do need to you know use food
banks I know own constituency and that
there's a range of people who do very
often at a time of Crisis need to to be
able to access food banks and you know
there's a huge amount of support for
those in the communities
um we should be using food banks in the
21st century Britain look I grew up in a
very uh poor uh background we don't have
but we didn't use food well what we need
to use food we had to get food Parcels
there weren't food banks in my day but
we did used to get help with respect
that was a while ago and I'm guessing
and it certainly you said that that's
never happened before but absolutely
absolutely that has been happening over
time so it's okay I'm not saying it's
okay but people do struggle and it's
really important that when people do
struggle that help and support is
available but to pretend that people
have been struggling uh it is a new
thing is absolutely not the case as you
say it was a while ago that I was a
young child but we used to get help with
beautiful with disrespect no no of
course it's true but I used to get help
with uniforms you know we used to get
help with Foods we used to get help with
you know and that's what communities do
whether it was the church in my day or
whether it's food banks now that's how
you know we should be supporting people
but we're paying our military enough and
they shouldn't be using food banks look
I you know I'm not going to comment I
don't have enough knowledge about the
military but I do know that you know in
my constituency people do need help and
it's right and proper that we support
them when they do and the government has
been giving record amounts of support
this year particularly the energy
crisis we've been paying half of
people's electricity bills on average
across the country well absolutely
because uh Energy prices are now
starting to come down but when people
need help whether that was through covid
through things like furlough or whether
through the energy crisis with paying
half of people's electricity bills we do
step in when we absolutely need to
support